are we gonna do this one we're gonna do
it songwriter I mean that's what song
yeah yeah you know the song wait wait
wait wait
if I do yeah close world you will leave
me alone
right okay because your kid this is
effectively a felony yeah yeah come on
come on come on okay okay in the mirror
in the me receiver altogether right
happy family here we go okay you ready
to sing the song I'm ready to sing your
song ready yes okay are you rolling
I'm always roll are you ready you ready
yes and go United States Canada Mexico
Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru no no no you
want me to sing the song just go the
song dude okay the ones that lose you
easy I'm a Indianapolis Indiana that
that's wackos America that's what Jess
Harnell sang it's the same composer
Randy Rogel but it's about the states
and the capitals I sing about the
countries of the world you mean you put
me through all this for your
for your stupid thing and they don't
even know a song you want from me
whatever just do Leonardo I'm Raphael
well I was Raphael I'm not Leonardo
so you're batting a thousand son because
I'm not the right guy so can we just
leave now so I can you know not send you
to prison because this is not cool who
are you again I'm Frank Welker okay good
do Optimus Prime I I'm not Frank Welker
I'm actually Peter Cullen good to
spongebob I'm actually Nancy Cartwright
Lisa Simpson
very close that would be dan
Castellaneta um I'm just going to UM get
out yeah I think that yeah yeah but you
but you've been of great support